what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard
and this is the channel where we talk
about all things data data science
statistics and programming so subscribe
for all kinds of content just like this
if you haven't already
and hit the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
so this is going to be another video in
my r tutorial series
and specifically today for the first
time we're going to be diving into shiny
so for those of you who are totally
unfamiliar with what shinee even is
it's basically a framework inside of r
where you can design
and share with other people interactive
web applications
it's wonderful because all the things
that typically go behind
interactive web applications things like
javascript html css
for the overwhelming most part you don't
have to be familiar with any of that
stuff
shiny exists purely in our code and so
once you design an app using shiny you
can either
share it with another user of r just by
sharing your code with them
or there are a number of locations that
you can actually host these apps for
sharing with a broader audience
now i do want to caution you with shiny
at its heart the fundamentals to it are
relatively straightforward
but there's definitely a learning curve
to it especially as you build up and
start to design
more and more complex applications and
it's not where you want to start with r
so
don't watch this tutorial if you know
nothing about things like manipulating
data
or using ggplot for data visualization
so i would consult my earlier tutorials
or other resources to learn those sorts
of things before you get into shiny
but what we're going to do here assuming
that you have
at least a basic working knowledge of r
is
we're going to start from this gallery
that's hosted directly on the rstudio
website
and there will be a link in the
description to this and we're going to
go through
three different apps here now they're
all going to be designed in
slightly different ways but once again
the fundamentals behind them are going
to be the same
now this is exactly how you want to
start
with learning shiny you want to learn
the fundamentals and the anatomy
of these apps so let's start over here
with this k-means app
so what we have is we have the app over
on the left two-thirds of the screen
and then on the right here we have the
actual code to the app
and you'll notice it's a very
straightforward app you can select an x
variable or a y variable or the number
of clusters
we can just change these and then the
things which are actually getting
plotted
in this graph so the variables that are
getting mapped to it are going to change
similarly we can bump up or down uh this
count of different
clusters here now if we take a look at
the code over on the right
you'll notice that there are two
distinct components to this app
and that's this ui component and this
server component
now that's going to be the case all of
the time with various apps
and we'll see that there are different
ways of sort of formatting this
so right here these two are separated
there is a ui.r
section or a server.r section
now alternatively you can put them all
inside of one single
uh app script and we're going to see an
example of that
but fundamentally we have two different
parts the ui
and the server now let's start with the
ui code to get a feel for what's going
on here
so don't worry about this first line of
code here too much all they're doing
there is just
storing the names of the iris data set
into this uh
there's vector where you want to focus
is this page with sidebar
page with sidebar that function is
basically setting up the
the grand layout for the entire app so
we just want to have a
sidebar on the side that's where the
inputs can be selected
where mainly the user's eyes are going
to be focused on this main panel here
so you'll notice there's this header
panel as the first thing
inside this function that's just setting
up the header
it takes a string which will be the
header of the app
then there's the sidebar panel and it
has three inputs that it takes
there's this select input x variable
is the name and then the actual
name of the input which we can reference
inside the server and we'll see that in
a moment is
x col now the options here that you can
select from
are theirs so in the x variable we can
just
select from the different names of the
iris data set
a very similar thing is going on with
the y variable input here it's just that
automatically they're selecting
the second name uh from the iris data
set
and then there's this numeric input so
you can basically just select a number
uh the default is three the minimum is
one and the maximum is nine
we can see if we toggle this it just
goes up to nine here
and once again the name of this thing is
cluster count but the name of the actual
input that gets mapped inside the server
side
is clusters again we're going to see
that later
and then in the main panel is just this
plot output
that's being called plot one which again
will make more sense when we look on the
server side
so the server script basically just
consists of a function
that has three inputs those are input
output and session and then this
function is going to have a variety of
different smaller functions defined
inside of it
and we're going to step through these
one by one so you'll notice up front
that we have this
reactive thing going on here now
this is one of the things that trips
newcomers to shiny up
more than anything now here's the idea
you'll see that just inside the function
what we're doing here is pretty simple
all we're doing is
subsetting the iris data set so we just
want to subset it to include
the variable we're defining with the x
variable
or selecting with the x variable and the
variable that we're selecting
for the y variable remember here this
x variable thing and y variable thing
those are just labels
but the actual inputs are called x col
and y col so we're referencing those
here
their input dollar sign x coal and input
dollar sign y
coal that's how we reference these
inputs
but here's the thing suppose all that i
did here was just
take out the reactive parts and i just
said selected data
is going to be equal to this thing right
here
well what would happen is r would just
trip an error message then and said that
you're doing something
outside of a reactive context so
something that we need to do
whenever we're referencing something
that we're defining on the input side so
again x col and y call we're setting
those ourselves to be
sepal width and petal length
respectively
now if we want to reference those things
that we're
selecting as inputs ourselves they need
to be
in some kind of reactive context now
that reactive context could be
just a regular function it could be a
reactive
object or it could be one of these
render functions
so again it's a little counter-intuitive
and weird to newcomers of shiny just
remember that if you're referencing
something that's being defined as an
input
it needs to be inside of a reactive
function
a regular function or a
or this family of render functions
so we create this selected data reactive
object
all it is is a data frame that's uh
based on
the columns that we've selected
ourselves
then we create this clusters reactive
object
now again this is based on things that
we've selected ourselves
that's selected data reactive object
from before
but also the clusters that we've
determined in the input here as well
now we've got this output dollar sign
plot 1
thing which is the main thing that you
see inside the main panel
now it's created through the render plot
function
and all the main output that you get in
a shiny app is going to come from this
family of render functions
we'll see more examples of them in some
of these other apps here
but it's ultimately pretty
straightforward because all it's doing
is creating
a plot based on the selected data
reactive
and the clusters reactive and just
creating points based on that
so at its heart nothing super
complex is going on here it's just that
we
set these inputs they then get
used to create reactive objects which
then get used
inside a render plot function
so now that hopefully that makes maybe a
little bit of sense
let's see some more examples of it now
let's move over and look at this single
file shiny app here and now this
app is actually even simpler than the
last one
but we're going to step through the code
here to it because i want to compare and
contrast various things to that last app
that you saw
starting right from the top you'll
notice that
before we had two scripts we had a ui.r
and a server.r here on the other hand
we have one script app.r
but it's got a ui object and then a
server function
and then right at the end we just call
this thing
so we use a shiny app function ui equals
ui
server equals server that's the two
inputs and then we just call the app
that way
these are two different ways that you
can set the app up
ultimately it doesn't matter that much i
strongly prefer this fashion actually
just because the ui
and the server really are two very
distinct components
and i like setting them up that way but
if you prefer this approach
you're welcome to do that now let's look
at the components just like we did
before
so remember with the k-means example
our grand layout for the ui was the page
with sidebar
our grand layout for this ui is this
bootstrap
page thing which is kind of just a
simpler layout
so things are going to run from top to
bottom
the first input is the number of
observations
again the input is called n but the
label is called number of
obs we see it up here so we defined a
global variable up top
that's n equals 200 and that's set as
the default
for this input n but we can change that
here
you'll see that the app is changing as a
result and then
inside the ui we have the plot output
which is just called
plot now in the server here
uh they've set it up so there's only two
uh inputs to the server function that's
input and output and there's just one
single thing going on here that's the
output
dollar sign plot uh object here
so it's created once again through this
render plot function
and on the inside remember this is
based on an input that we are selecting
ourselves
this and input again we're selecting
that
but we're okay here we don't have to do
anything with the uh reactive
functionality because
we can put these inputs that we select
ourselves inside the render family of
functions
so render plot render a histogram
based on a uniform distribution of size
equal to n
that is all that we're doing here so
are you beginning to get the hang of it
behind just at least these
very simple and straightforward shiny
apps
the last app that we're gonna look at is
this word cloud app
and now this one is a little bit more
complex than the first two
but hopefully if you understand the
ideas behind the first two
you're gonna understand this one too
there's just a few
things about this that make it different
and a little bit more
uh complex so up front there's actually
three components to this one
there's the ui.r server.r but then
there's this optional
global.r so the thing here is
you'll notice all they're doing here is
calling some libraries
creating this books list and then
they're using
functionality from these packages to
create this
get term matrix functionality
now the thing here is we could have just
stuck
all this stuff inside ui.r
right at the top but once you start
stacking stuff
in here like the more stuff that we need
to define
up front that's not being really
determined by our inputs
if we start just stacking that at the
top of ui.r
it starts to get difficult to read
pretty quickly
and so this is just a clean a way of
organizing the app that if you're
sharing with somebody else
uh they're going to thank you for now
let's go ahead and take a look at the ui
so the grand layout here is the fluid
page
so there's a title panel that's the word
cloud
and then we sort of have a layout inside
of the layout
so similar to what we did uh in the
k-means example
we're setting up a sidebar layout
where inside this sidebar layout
we have two parts we have the sidebar
panel
that's the section where we're choosing
a book we've got this change button
and these sliders and then once again
for our main panel we have this plot
output here
now in the sidebar we have select input
that's going to be called selection but
the label is choose a book
we have this action button thing which
we're going to see in a minute here
uh this hr thing is just that stands for
horizontal rule and it's creating
a gray space here and then we have these
sliders
so minimum frequency and then maximum
number of words
and then once again inside the main
panel we're just creating this word
cloud which is a plot object
now let's go ahead and look on the
server side i'm going to move my
picture over to the corner here that way
you can see everything that's going on
here
now the first thing we do inside the
server is we want to create this terms
object here and now again this is a
reactive
because this object is going to depend
on things which we are selecting in the
inputs here
but here's some things to take note of
if we move the sliders around here
notice that
the app is updating however under choose
a book here
if we make a different uh selection here
notice the app doesn't change if we hit
the change button here though then all
of a sudden the app does
does update it does change also
look at the bottom right here really
quick
you'll see that there was a very quick
just fraction of a second
status update that was going on if we
look inside of this terms reactive
what's actually going on here is terms
is going to update
when we hit the change button so
remember the actual update is called
update but we put a label on it called
change
we set that up in the ui however terms
is dependent on the input selection
so when we're choosing a book here the
terms are obviously dependent on that
however when we change the input
the app doesn't update and we have this
kind of both ways by putting this
inside of the isolate wrapper here
so again terms is dependent on
input dollar sign selection but by
wrapping this inside of isolate
we can have terms be dependent on input
a selection
without actually changing every time we
change this thing here
there's a little bit more a wrapping of
functionality that's going on here
like the with progress that's basically
creating that progress bar
in the bottom right so that it's really
useful with larger and more complex
apps where it can take a little bit
longer to actually
update but that way if the user hits the
change button
they know the change is actually
occurring it's just sort of a formality
here that they're setting that up inside
of
inside of isolate now the next thing
that happens inside the server
is we're creating this word cloud
underscore rep
functionality in order to make this uh
word cloud drawing repeatable
now notice this is the only thing that
we've seen inside of a server function
so far
that's not inside the reactive context
or inside the render family of functions
actually all that we've seen so far is
render plot but the reason we can do
this here is because this word cloud
underscore rep functionality
it is not dependent on any of our inputs
the terms reactive it's dependent on
the input update here as well as the
input selection
the output plot that we're going to do
below here is
dependent on the reactive which was
dependent on things that we were setting
up earlier
however word cloud underscore rep
doesn't matter
it's not dependent on anything else so
we can set that up inside the server
function
next we're going to call the render plot
function
the exact same way that we did in the
other apps
and we're going to actually use that
word cloud underscore rep
functionality that brings us our word
cloud
okay now the last thing that i want to
show you in this tutorial
is my favorite cheat sheet for shiny
there are multiple cheat sheets out
there for shiny
but this one is my personal favorite
because i find it the most user friendly
personally and obviously the link to it
will be in the description of this video
right up front it breaks down that the
structure of a shiny app is broken down
as
the server and the ui components with
some
other optional components that you can
put inside of the app folder
but at the end of the day you do have a
server component and a ui component
now if we actually start at the second
page here with the ui
there's some solid explanation here to
some of the things that you saw in some
of these apps earlier
but it breaks down that as a general
rule
you're going to start with your grand
layout as fluid page
doesn't have to be that way you have
other options but that's
by far the most common grand layout
and then like we saw in that third app
there are various ways of setting up
layouts inside of layout things like the
sidebar layout split layout
flow layout slash input panel
or just setting up various fluid rows
and then the coding framework for
setting these things up
is detailed below now if we scroll back
up to the top to look at the
description for the server component
there's
details to some of the things we've
talked about in this tutorial on the
left hand side
but what i really want to focus on is at
the upper right
the render functions so we only saw
render plot
in this tutorial but there are a variety
of other options
we have render data table render image
render plot
we've got render print and render text
for text output
then we have render table that's
different from render data table because
a data table is a more
uh interactive type of functionality
then we've also got this render ui
which is one of the most powerful things
that you can actually do inside of shiny
that's the subject for things that we're
going to see in different tutorials
similarly if we go to the bottom of the
page where reactivity
is detailed it breaks down some of the
information on the just the overall
concept of reactivity
but just remember that inside the server
component
when we're doing things that are
dependent on our inputs
we are going to have to wrap things
inside of
the render family of functions or this
reactive functionality
now we can make the reactive
functionality a little bit more
uh complex with the isolate
functionality that we saw or observe
that's something that we'll see in
future tutorials but at the end of the
day
if you took nothing away from this
tutorial just remember that we have a ui
and a server component that are separate
and then reactivity in order to create
objects in the server
which are dependent on our inputs so
thanks for watching this video
in future shiny tutorials we're going to
dive deeper into it we're going to
explore
some of the more advanced
functionalities behind it and we're
going to create these apps ourselves
step by step
but i think something that you can take
away from this is if you go to the
gallery of shiny apps
you can start if you have the basic idea
by creating very similar sorts of apps
to these ones
but then there's a whole spectrum of
more complex apps
as you move through the shiny gallery
and so
if you go through these apps and they
make sense to you
before long you're going to be able to
create very similar apps to these
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it consider
sharing it smash the like button and
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future
until then richard on data